شراكه عسكريه بين موسكو وطهران تتعمق وفق
نتائج استخباراتيه امريكيه اعلن عنها
البيت الابيض تصريحات المسؤول في مجلس
الامن القومي كشفت قيام روسيا ببناء مصنع
لانتاج المسيرات الهجوميه مرجحه جهزيته
للعمل بكامل طاقته بحلول اوائل العام
المقبل صوره ملتقطه بالاقمار الاصطناعيه
عرضتها الاداره الامريكيه حددت موقع
المصنع في منطقه الابوجا الاقتصاديه
الخاصه على مسافه نحو 900 كيلومتر شرقيه
موسكو خريطه الطريق التي تستخدمها ايران
لشحن المعدات بعد تصنيعها في طهران وفق
الاداره الامريكيه تتمثل بنقلها برا الى
مدينه امير اباد المطله على بحر قزوين
ليتم بعدها شحن المسيرات عبر سفن روسيه
الى مدينه محج قلعه الوقعه جنوبيه روسيا
من ثم الى مدينه بريمورسكو واختارسك
المطله على بحر ازوف وقاعده
في مقاطعه
في حربها على اوكرانيا وتحديدا لضرب كييف
وفي تقرير سابق لشبكه السي ان ان كشف ان
روسيا اشترت مئات الطائرات المسيره من
ايران وغالبا ما تستخدم صفنا مظلمه لاخفاء
تحركاتها وخوفا من انخراط شركات او حكومات
عن غير قصد في برنامج ايران للطائرات بدون
طيار ابدت واشنطنيتها اصدار احاطه لاحقه
لتبيان كيفيه حصول ايران بشكل غير قانوني
على المكونات اللازمه لبناء مسيراتها اياد
حمود العربيه
المزيد
الانسانيه والوثائقيه والتقارير الاخباريه
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات